lieu de mon disque dur je joue se
retrouvent sur merde a embouti un un jeu
on doit faire du dit alors c'est un
petit peu comme surgi un simulateur donc
pour ceux qui ont vu la vidéo que j'ai
fait sur cette gen simulator c'est un
peu le même principe on a un bras pour
cette fois c'est un bras tout robotique
car un petit peu un petit peu puis
votation cette phrase oh là rien dire et
donc le but ça va être de faire un tel
on a des instructions à de t-bag extra
sugary d'âge of milk serbe
voilà donc la faut ajouter du thé un
truc de thé alors donne aux brigades
donc ça keep calm and mighty à débat
alors attendez est-ce qu'on peut pas
prendre ça doit être les sachets d très
bien il faut prendre une tasse alors à
prendre doivent apprendre à l'équipe
qu'à mme may hamm est tombé aux [ __ ]
j'aimerais pas avoir à aller horrible ce
vin rouge est une espèce de [ __ ] à
mouches un peu hein
bush a donné attendait j'aimerais bien
prend la tasse sur la démo est bon on va
faire le thé dans ma bouche parce qu'on
a plus de traces
alors allez [ __ ] faut recommencer
avait hâte en faut vraiment y aller tout
doucement c'est pas un jeu qui qui
blague hein ah ah voilà john tasse de
thé le salut robotique bonjour alors
attendez bonjour je vais tenter de te
prendre délicatement jeunes tasse de thé
afin gerra peu edward aux mains d'argent
oui oh elle est suspendue à un fil
invisible
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans non on va
tomber à au nom j'ai perdu la tasse f10
oui alors chante mais alors pas mal de
f10 dans cet art à prendre cet aspect
avec cet homme tout à fait bizarre
voilà y est prometteuse pour la dass
pour la tasse boit la tasse
c'est pas attention aux grecs bullens et
oui oui oui parfait vous non à revient
non je t'aime et juliette
non
mais c'est impossible de prendre un truc
qu'on voulait prendre un truc avec une
main comme ça sans déconner à fin mai
bien là mais je sais que j'aime un
blizzard vient là voilà comme ça voilà
alors finalement ce jeu va se
transformer en un tuto cuisine comment
faire déboires à buller à la poêle super
[ __ ] mais cette main aurait peut-être
une guitare fille avoue regarder on
ajoute ça et ça et on est parti
bon j'avoue ma guitare fait un peu 3 cm
pour ça arrive bon arfa attendait oui
attention nom revient la cheffe du thé
non non et non oui c'est bon il a
atteint sachez juste là alors à de t-bag
il est là il est là il est là attention
on va essayer de le prendre bien musique
épique alors à la fausse joie ça s'est
vu sur mon visage mais je veux pas tout
casser je veux juste prendre mon [ __ ]
de sacs de thé mais prônent le oui
attention attention attention non non
mais tout part en sucette
non mais c'est impossible est ce qu'on
va faire la technique raclette attendait
comme ça mais casse toi la voilà à vatan
c'est l'heure de la technique raclette
et je vois valeco j'allais matin sans
déconner c'est impossible quoi puis ils
ont mis une espèce de musique de cirque
on va pas en faire tout un cirque
bon je suis déchaînez la faut que
j'arrête tout ses blagues ça s'appelle
tout vient je ne ferais pas de mal avec
ma jeune margot plus des fois il ya des
doigts ils partent complètement aux
couilles
quand ils s'écrasent contre non merde
dans son bulletin allez on y retourne
alors on va mettre notre main bien à
l'horizon vers regard des samares
ridicule quoi bon jour
venez les copains qu'on va jouer à la
marelle
oula et maintenant l'abord du robot wars
de la tasse oui non [ __ ] merde merde à
dire que j'ai acheté ce jeu 7 euros pour
ne pas réussir à faire la première
épreuve jeter mais au jeu des sommets
c'est début d'une grande histoire
d'amour entre nous au coq est un art est
me demande pas de me calmer un coquin et
c'est là qu'il faut mettre un truc doter
un sachet de thé donnant alors attendez
non quoi j'ai effleuré le machin et il a
dit ok je mets cas salute et ses espèces
péter norman ça assez on a mis un sachet
de thé oui est ce que quelqu'un fait ça
dans la vraie vie le matin tôt il sert
un thé absolument pas assez génial assez
génial alors alors alors alors alors à
twitter oui
attendez attendez attendez attendez va
prendre leur apprendre la tasse hop
comme ça de la sorte pose-toi
délicatement j'en passe or mais vous
avez vu mais la finesse pour dire est
que j'ai fait du tout ma vie avec une
non faut mettre faut mettre de tvo faut
mettre le fauve le haut le ta mère je
panique alors bas il est là le sucre
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] c'est carrément trop bien
c'est la première fois que tu feras je
sais pas jouer en multi est ce qu'on va
faire la technique du pouce avec les
doigts non mais c'est [ __ ] d'araignée
robot que je peux le servir faut le
servir ou faut le servir ou faut le
servir ou poussières ou me fait pas ce
coup là fait pas ce coup là vous n'avez
pas le droit à moi je vous explique les
choses très clairement un bon on va
tenter dans la nuit
je me sens pas du tout je sens que c'est
pas la gauche fait d'écouter olala avec
les petites assiettes et tout olala
comme les indiens là qui font qu'ils
mettent 1 1 mètre entre la tva la tasse
j'ai bien tout honneur on a tous essayé
ça vous l'avez bien et on en a tous
foutus absolument partout à moins que je
ne sois seul je dois faire un tour ça
fait mal noté robert sauvé par ses
poteaux
allez tous vous faire on s'envole avec
notre bras l'on peut vraiment s'envoler
doit watts
oh c'est ça la vérité nous n'étions nous
aussi qu'une boule de l'est dans ce
monde
c'était un monde parallèle qui n'était
qu'une misérable boules de l'est voilà
j'ai fait ma mission avec un projet que
c'était voilà tu fais ton tu es et tu te
dis serre le jeu ne te dirai pas où mais
sérieux allez vas-y serre 1
j'espère que vous ont rappelé aux trois
nouvelles vidéos qui tournent bise à
bientôt au revoir
m
attendez
en fait j'ai pas millions
om fg vous êtes un million vous attend